celui que je vais recevoir maintenant
est un trésor bijoux en une espèce en
voie de disparition
un homme du xviiie siècle d'une culture
incroyable qui manie aussi bien la
langue parlée que la langue écrite voici
jean d'ormesson
bonsoir
c'est pas du sadisme à nous avoir mis
tous les deux à côté
j'y vais un peu plus grand que vous mais
bon ça se voit moins quand on est assis
sa soif en effet si vous avez bien mal
on est très heureux nous vient de la
part trop troubler non
zazie tout à l'heure un petit peu quand
même on m'a nommé on est très contents
de vous avoir sur toute l'année dit
beaucoup de bien de vous on a dit que
j'étais intelligent tout le temps parce
que nous on disait qu'avec des moments
où tu es quand même un peu bête quoi
mais vous tout le temps visés que des
trucs intelligents on va voir ça lorsque
vous êtes dans votre phase bardot dans
votre phase garbo alors j'explique à vos
amis téléspectateurs jean d'ormesson il
ya deux positions c'est soyez dans sa
phase de bardos iris montre à la
télévision soient nos surfaces garbo
série reste planqué chez lui là vous
êtes plutôt en ce moment je vous ai lu
sur une autre chaîne aux jo zette prison
avec trois bars donnons lui limite à
c'est bientôt la fin d'un code-barres
d'eau vous connaissez saisie car palmade
ok représentante commerciale exonhit
linda hardy qui se ronge les ongles
parce qu'elle connaît pas la ville aux
mille et michel noir qui est beaucoup
plus marron depuis qu'il a arrêté la
politique
alors jean d'ormesson vous avez déclaré
que vous pouvez déclarer ces cioran mais
vous ça pourrait de vous j'ai connu
toutes les formes de déchéance y compris
le succès se débrouille très bien ça
vous caractérise très bien et vous vous
avez dit en revanche les honneurs je les
méprise mais je ne déteste pas forcément
ce que je méprise ou que ces deux
phrases mais finissent à la perfection
je pense qu'une bonne façon de
débarrasser les alliances et les avoir
oui on y pense moi que si on les apprend
alors vous êtes écrivain il ya un livre
qui s'appelle qui est là qui s'appelle
le rapport gabriel dont on va parler
tout à l'heure voilà je montre à la
caméra comme on fait la tdg ch énorme le
fait bien
donc écrivain journaliste
si enfin c'est pas aussi important c'est
pas aussi important en fait dans l'autre
la phrase de gîtes qui disait en faire
que des citations sont désormais sans il
parle que par quitter le journalisme
c'est ce qui sera moins intéressant
demain qu'aujourd'hui 1 je pense à la
wii c'est pour ça que j'écrivais des
vivres oui l'académicien l'académie sert
à rester bon hiver vous avez dit vous ai
fait aussi des grosses têtes
berterretche et alors vous jouer dans le
prochain film de jean luc godard et bien
oui en principe oui mais c'est une somme
que le tournage est sans cesse reportée
avant ça devait déjà avoir lieu la
semaine dernière ça a été encore
reportée alors peut-être qu'on ne verra
pas en avant elle c'est trois fois pour
jean luc godard enfin franchement jean
d'ormesson faut le film et feront
profiter bien non mais il vous a écrit
ce bel éloge de l'amour le film il vous
a écrit faisait pas reconnu sa signature
comment j'ai reçu une lettre et g j'ai
mal lu sa signature j'ai cru que c'était
une dame qui m'écrivait et je lui ai
répondu madame madame on verra ça dans
un an et l'a donc après quand vous avez
vous a rappelé donc et vous avez déclaré
on ne refuse pas un film de la finale
justine belle de la bien sûr alors on
parle un petit peu du rhin pour gabriel
en 86 donc bien avant d'écrire le
rapport gabriel vous aviez déclaré je
crois qu'il ya un dieu mais je n'en suis
pas sûr car il ne s'est jamais donné la
peine d'engager la conversation avec moi
s'il a changé maintenant c'est fait
puisque dans ce livre dieu qui est en
colère qu'on veut que l'ange gabriel que
vous appelez kabylie 007
et qui lui donne une mission c'est celle
d'aller demander aux hommes de
s'expliquer sur les désordres de
l'histoire donc l'ange gabriel va sur
terre et poche 123 grand cru entendre
des sons s'étant plaints de faire
trempette dans la méditerranée et il
vous demande de raconter votre vie pour
écrire un rapport pour dieu c'est ça
voilà vingt dieu dieu aimait pourtant dû
est mécontent des hommes vous savez il a
été déjà d'autres fois il ya été
mécontent au moment du déluge il a bien
essayé de donné l'histoire le monde avec
les luges qui était d'ailleurs partiale
en faveur des poissons non à 6 me
propose évidemment
et alors il avait abandonné à ce moment
là et maintenant il est encore plus
mécontent il faut que ça va plus mal je
trouve que n'est pas content et alors
les données dernière chance aux hommes
et et il envoie gabriel qui est déjà
descendu plusieurs fois qui a rencontré
abraham qui a rencontré la vierge marie
qui a rencontré manu et puis cette fois
là il tombe sur moi sans rien en faire
l'ange gabriel viens sur terre sur qui
tombe d'ormesson bien sûr maintenant
faire en faire alors y'a un truc
excellent j'ai pas évidemment je vais
pas citer tout le bouquin parce que si
on n'est pas là pour ça simplement dire
aux gens de le lire mes pages 356 c'est
un truc très rigolo qui résume bien le
bouquin parce que c'est quand même
vachement bien vous dites vous raconter
à l'engin une bonne partie du dernier
siècle s'est déroulée sous le signe des
jumeaux sanglant hitler et staline
ennemi mortel à lier entre eux par la
faiblesse et la faute des démocraties
libérales et là où c'est vraiment génial
le drame de mon époque c'est qu'il
fallait choisir entre eux je crois que
c'est un résumé du xxème siècle qui est
extraordinaire dire que tout le drame du
20e siècle
c'est tout les gens se sont plus obligés
d'être obligé de choisir entre hitler et
staline lors c'était la même chose
évidemment il fallait choisir entre eux
est évidemment s'est retrouvé dans le
même camp que staline et je crois qu'il
fallait se retrouver dans comme staline
vous n'avez pas le choix il ya la peste
et le choléra et il faut choisir entre
eux et toutefois on ne peut pas être
neutre en tous les cas c'est toujours
vrai que l'inscription bien sûr c'est
une bonne description du 20e siècle on
parlait du pouvoir vous dire
je n'ai pas aimé le pouvoir car sa
prétention me fait rire
je dois vous avez exercé le pouvoir
j'aime pas bon pour recevoir des ordres
ouais mais je n'aime pas beaucoup non
plus en donner donc il vaut mieux que je
m'abstienne de ce genre d'activité et
j'ai été j'ai été j'ai dirigé à journal
mais un journal je la veux particulier
parce qu'on ne donne pas vraiment dans
un journaliste celui qui va donner des
ordres à l'elysée
mais j'aime pas beaucoup les formes de
pouvoir c'est vrai j'aime pas le subit
et je n'aime pas beaucoup l'exercer mais
je sais pas l'éloge vous savez il faut
bien qu'ils aient des gens qui exercent
je n'ai aucun jeu n'est pas du tout de
dédain pour les les gens qui exercent le
pouvoir simplement moi j'en suis pas je
n'en suis pas friand vous voilà en fait
vous avez eu comme du pouvoir aussi
parce qu'il y avait une certaine
culpabilité chez vous de ne pas avoir su
garder le château de famille oui bien
sûr
pourquoi est ce qu'on écrit des ifs à ce
qu on a des chocs sentimentaux à
l'oreille ou bien pourquoi est-ce qu'on
veut créer des chansons pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait du théâtre pourquoi est ce qu
on fait du cinéma pourquoi est ce qu on
plaint parce qu'on a eu choc
sentimentaux alors il chauffe
sentimentaux on les connaît mais il peut
y avoir les différentes espèces et
perdre une maison parce qu'on n'est pas
capable de la garde et c'est aussi à
chaque sortie tout de suite c'est à vous
qui parle
non mais c'est nous on existe le plus
marqué les très jolies saisir non je
vois bien vous êtes un peu jaloux
mais non vous avez vous avez déclarez
vous avez déclaré les premiers les
premiers livres on les écrit toujours
pour plaire aux filles
oui un crime non non si j'étais une
remarque je sais pas mais moi je vais
vous déjà vu un papier montherlant
kadidia l'amour il ya les vivres il n'y
a rien donc voilà oui je rêve je crois
que l amour les oreilles et voilà pardon
moi je suis et dans l'amour line dans le
rien on choisit vous ne trouvez pas
craquant jean d'ormesson
l'esprit est ce qu'il ya de plus
séduisant agent puisse dire je veux dire
un truc quand même il a déclaré une de
mes plus grandes passions étaient pour
une femme de 15 ans mon aîné aujourd'hui
avec des femmes de 15 ans de plus c'est
un peu difficile il 15 ans maire rêve de
vous rencontrer et très jolie veuve rêve
vous savez le le coup le plus classique
qu'on me fait ces jouets arrivée les
jeunes filles ravissantes qu'il faut
faire dédicacer un livre est la phrase
classique était ma mère a tellement
d'admiration pour dwan et puis ça a
changé il ya quelques temps et c'est ma
grand-mère et l'on doit jeter chez
gallimard
je raconte cette histoire et à ce moment
là y'a une stagiaire qui entre
ravissante charmant et je vous assure qu
elle a dit je crois que vous êtes à
lagny devons garder
vous avez déclaré le beau décor bien a
déclaré ce jeu vous faites beaucoup de
citations
ah ben moi c'est nous les autres que je
ferai quand je me cite attendait si
j'avais été une femme j'aurais aimé
mener les hommes en bourrique
vous auriez été terrible ces derniers
teen adorait ça le fonds btg venir je
suis très favorable aux femmes oui vous
emmener en bourrique et enfin oui
comment que je vous croyais oui comment
quand on vous avez été un bourreau des
coeurs
si vous saviez si seulement je vous
racontais à moi tout seul vous racontez
nous votre histoire d'amour alors bâti
soit la pire la plus que vous la
raconter tout de suite à jour un jour je
suis invitée avec greta garbo
on est trop instable et j'aime beaucoup
un tag à rebours est pris d'une espèce
de folie je me met à chantonner le
pinphone coffee shop of liberty est ce
que ça dit quelque chose je suis dit ah
oui et c'est la chanson de l'ange bleu
ouais je sais comment la mélodie voilà
un appel à vous voulez vous faire
chanter
ce collier dit elle je chante s'arrête à
nouveau l amour et l vous c'est comme on
insiste quand on fait les gars et j'ai
dit j'ai tellement aimé l'ange bleu elle
ne dit rien j'ai dit je vous êtes
tellement admirée dans l'ange bleu et
surtout vers moi et me dit je vois que
vous me prenez pour marlène dix ans plus
tard je dîne à côté de ma mère dit
vraiment on s'entend bien on s'entend
vraiment bien et elle me dit même ce qui
était assez rare elle me dit venez boire
j'habite avenue montaigne je crois
qu'elle habitait vraiment un homme et je
lui ai dit je vais vous raconter une
histoire tordante je lui raconte cette
histoire elle m'a tourné le dos elle m'a
plu donc la chance à m alors là
maintenant on arrive à en arriver là je
vous en parler parce que j'aimais quand
on a beaucoup parlé mais enfin quand
même je vous en parle et me trouveront
donc ça tombe un jour enfin vous
regardez
je regarde tous soit 157 qu'est ce qu'il
y ait de caisse qui disons le sans
ambages 350 kwh voilà la merde donc jean
d'ormesson prend un petit déjeuner avec
françois mitterrand un jour de la
passation de pouvoir le 17 mai 95 g
skill papote tous les deux comme ça
gentiment il parle de la sphère bousquet
limité on lui dit cette phrase qui a
fait dont on parle depuis la sortie de
vie malheureusement pas là on a parlé un
peu trop de sade pour ça qu avant j'ai
voulu qu'on va me dire qu' il veut autre
chose dans le livre et mitterrand dit à
jean d'ormesson dont vous constatez là
pendant d'affaires bousquet
l'influencent puissante et nos cibles du
lobby juif en france voilà alors après
de gaulle qui avait dit que les juifs
étaient un peuple sûr de lui et
dominateur bissonnette y avait un dessin
de steam dans l'express qui est
extraordinaire où il y avait un type qui
est derrière des barbelés dans un camp
de concentration il y avait il avait
remis la phrase c'était d'une violence
estime qu'elle est là donc françois
mitterrand dit ça on peut pas penser que
vous auriez crise à si c'était pas vrai
parce que de toute façon personne ne
force plus que les femmes non d'autant
plus le forage d'autant plus qu'il l'a
dit à plusieurs faire ça voilà enfin
murray la même chose en vue ce qu'ils
avaient eu le procès qu'on a fait on
manie fallait pas le répéter
oui pas vous pas comme ça pas maintenant
ouais et alors évidemment moi moi c'est
mon droit le plus strict sur ce truc
qu'il n'avait pas du tout demandé le
secret gens vous connaissent en même
temps
vous savez j'ai même cru de bonne foi
qu'il me l'avait dit pour que je le
répète je ne crois plus maintenant je
pense que quand on lui permet de
bousquet celle l'exaspéraient et que lui
à l'ess et il y avait de quoi est il a
laissé échapper sa ville un certain
nombre de réactions il est roger hanin
qui a dit que j'étais un crétin ridicule
oui tu l'as pikine communaux françois j
que pas très partagées non plus pense le
giro qui a dit il n'a pu se retenir de
faire dans sa culotte
oui pas très sympa non que jack lang
plus violent il avions utilise parfois
l'autre pour exprimer ses propres
sentiments serbe
il ya aussi jean daniel le patron du
nouvel obs qui a dit d'ailleurs françois
mitterrand lui avait dit à jean daniel
boone corriger si je me trompe
tout se passe en somme comme si ce lobby
d'antan par exister vraiment donc
quasiment ou jean daniel qui va
soupçonner d'être de droite jacques
attali fourbe aussi qui a dit plusieurs
interlocuteurs m'ont rapporté ce type de
propos cela explique mes distances avec
mitterrand alors qu'en fait il a pris
ses distances font sortir à la berd
vous savez j'ai été d'une discrétion
exquis hills où une façon de parler
second match 357 parce que avant avant
de d'entrée cette formule je n'en parle
pas d'un livre
mitterrand avait passé en vue avec moi
ou spectateurs muets le personnel
politique est alors il avait été surtout
sauvage sauvage avec les gens de son
bord et moi vous me connaissez très
courtois très bien élevé je lui disais
vous savez ce mon côté sont pas fort non
plus oui oui mais tu es sur le crétin
mais les miens commencé à dire une chose
et le ring alors si j'étais allé à la
télévision ou à la radio
et si jamais les wallace qui m'a dit de
untel untel je le dis à jamais mais vous
savez paris aurait sauté alors voyez
j'ai été très très modéré
jean christophe mitterrand lui
effectivement il a alors lui il a
approuvé son père jean christophe
mitterrand je te courante ça me
rappelait la mois non il a dit quand le
monde a titré mitterrand et
l'antisémitisme
il a écrit le monde fait partie de ces
caisses de résonance de certains monde
pourquoi pas d'un certain lobby juif
donc le fils de 8 ans boussouf dit c'est
que personne n'a mis en doute vos propos
de toute façon personne nulle mais plein
d'autres